ok marina ce la puoi fare benvenuti in
un nuovissimo video mi presento io sono
pinky glitzi glitz ho fatto un test
per scoprire qual è il mio nome da
unicorno era da tantissimo che non
faceva un video haul e ultimamente ho
comprato delle cosine sono stata anche a
miami a capodanno quindi ho fatto un
pochino di shopping anche lì ho comprato
qualcosina con i saldi qui a milano e
soprattutto sono andata a una svendita un
mese fa e mi sono dimenticata
assolutamente di farvi vedere cosa ha
comprato una svendita di un brand molto
molto famoso iniziamo subito proprio da
questo brand molto conosciuto alcuni di
voi che mi seguono su instagram si
ricorderanno che avevo detto che ero
andata a una svendita speciale ma non vi
volevo ancora dire di cosa per insomma
lasciarvi con la suspense e poi è
passato un mese diciamo che mi sono
dimenticata e quindi é arrivato il
momento di farvi vedere cosa ho comprato e
soprattutto svelarvi il brand iniziamo
proprio dalla svendita di moschino
allora è stata una svendita sofferta
ve lo dico avete presente i love shopping
la scena della svendita dove c'erano le
ragazze che si tiravano per i capelli
urlavano in preda al panico dello
shopping
ecco più o meno pochi ma
con la differenza che invece di starci
forse un'oretta ci sono stata circa 5 ore
perché comunque volevo provare tutto bene
eccetera eccetera
alla fine ho scelto i capi che vi sto
per far vedere perché erano quelli che
mi stavano meglio e di cui avevo più
bisogno quindi anche alle svendite
bisogna comunque ragionare non comprare
cose che poi non metterai mai partirei
subito con uno degli acquisti che ho
preferito appena l'ho visto me ne sono
innamorata sto parlando di questo fantastico
cappotto mi è piaciuto da subito perché
mixava il classico con il moderno con
questi inserti in pelle che gli davano un
tocco di aggressive in più e soprattutto
appena l'ho provato mi fittava alla
perfezione sembrava cucito appunto su di
me e quindi ho detto vabbè é mio non c'è bisogno di guardare altro l'ho trovato è mio
infatti l'ho preso secondo acquisto
della svendita di moschino è questa giacca
che io ho adorato perché è super
elegante ma allo stesso tempo ha questa
chiusura che ricorda molto i chiodi
di pelle modello biker e soprattutto è
corta come piace a me io ho soltanto
jeans pantaloni e gonne a vita alta
quindi questa è perfetta perché arriva
proprio sopra la vita dai ve la faccio
vedere faccio vedere come mi fitta
perché secondo me di fitta benissimo poi
magari mi sta male quindi a voi giudicare
magari mi tolgo questo cosí faccio un
po più la seriosa notate la bellezza
l'eleganza può essere usata sia la sera
sia di giorno con un look un po più
sportivo insomma arriviamo quindi al
terzo ed ultimo acquisto che a
differenza degli altri due è più un
capriccio perché non è che si può
mettere proprio tutti i giorni ma era
troppo troppo poco sobrio per lasciarlo
lì era proprio la sobrietà prima di
tutto e l'ho anche indossato in montagna
quindi secondo me alcuni di voi l'avranno
visto nella foto che ho pubblicato in montagna lo volete vedere non lo volete vedere haaaa
un bellissimo colbacco sobrio con
scritto moschino
perché in caso non volessi farlo sapere
che é di moschino
lo dice direttamente il cappello quindi sono a posto questo era il capitolo svendita di
moschino per quanto riguarda i saldi qui
a milano come al solito ho trovato poco o
niente nel senso che andavo nei negozi e
mi piaceva tutto ciò che faceva parte
della nuova collezione
l'unica cosa che sono riuscita a comprare
con i saldi quest'anno è un'altra giacca
nera però aspettate non partite subito
col pensare ha comprato due giacche uguali
no perché sono molto diverse adesso ve
lo dimostrerò questa infatti è una
fantastica giacca che ho preso da maje e a
differenza di quella di moschino ha un
taglio più dritto quindi da uomo e non
ha il cinturino ma ha i bottoni e
soprattutto è più lunga quindi adesso la
proverò e vi farò vedere che insomma non
arriva qui sopra la vita ma è più lunghi
na
io la trovo top perché é perfetta sia
sopra un jeans e un top con magari anche
la scarpa la sneaker oppure anche con la
tuta la tutta bella larga sotto e magari
una scarpa col tacco molto casual molto
street style
stavo pensando che questo video lo avrei
potuto intitolare haul video haul
giacche nere perché perché dopo le due
già che vi ho appena fatto vedere mi sono
ricordata che ne ho comprato un'altra
sempre nera cioè questa che però a
differenza delle altre più che un blazer
è un chiodo solo che invece di essere in
pelle é velluto nero come potete notare
con questi dettagli bottoncini e
cerniere oro quindi l'ho vista e ho detto
ok è mia e l'ho provata mi stava bene
quindi ho detto ok è definitivamente mia
adesso vi faccio vedere siete contenti
che mi provo le cose perché ogni tanto
quando anzi sempre quando faccio i video haul
mi dite marina ma non li provi mai noi
vogliamo vederli
facciamo anche un po' uno shooting cioè quanto è
carina col cartellino che esce quello é il
tocco di classe e quanto è carina
ragazzi io la amo e con questa sobrissima
coroncina io passerei agli acquisti
di miami infatti questa l'ho acquistata
a miami insieme al cerchiettino da unicorno
che ho utilizzato prima e nello stesso
negozio che era uno di quei negozi che io adoro dove ci sono trucchi cianfrusaglie
cerchiettini collanine bigiotteria quelli proprio dove tu passi due ore e compri di
tutto ho acquistato 260 ciglia finte
in america è pieno di ciglia finte qui
a milano c'é solo un negozio dove vado a
comprarle o vabbè da sephora in america
ovunque voi anche al supermercato
troverete ciglia finte e sono pazzesche
quindi ne ho provate un pó poi quando
ritornerò farò la scorta ma in questo
stesso negozio ho trovato questa cosa che
io trovo geniale
io uso il beauty blender lo sapete l'avete
visto anche nei miei tutorial e cosa
succede per non sporcarlo dove lo
conservo nel suo nella sua confezione di
plastica dove insomma lo trovate quando
lo comprate
peccato che si secca ovviamente essendo
chiuso e non prendendo aria quindi che
cosa ho trovato io in questo negozio il
contenitore per il beauty blender in
silicone proprio della marca beauty
blender voi infilate qua il vostro ovetto
il vostro beauty blender e verrà conservato ma
soprattutto si potrà a arieggiare il vano
contenitore in modo tale che non si
rovini e non si secchi io lo amo lo
adoro quando l'ho visto ho detto boh é mio mio questo
invece l'ho preso nel negozio di
havaianas salvo si è comprato un paio di
ciabattine iole avevo già quindi ho
dato un'occhiata in giro e ho visto
questa cosa qui e ho detto no vabbè ma è
quello che penso io
ragazzi questa è una borsettina in
silicone per la spiaggia
io non so voi ne ho parlato con edo e mi ha detto
che lui non sapeva l'esistenza di questa
cosa io mi compro sempre tutte le estati un
piccolo beauty case oppure uso le
custodie dei costumi sapete quelle di
plastica e ci metto dentro il telefono i
soldi e quando vado a fare una passeggiata
in spiaggia ovviamente non porto tutta
la borsa da spiaggia porto solo quel
borsellino con le cose più importanti
però tipo a miami mi è capitato che mi
cadesse in mare e si é bagnato tutto
quindi ho rischiato di perdere il
telefono e soprattutto se non lo
prendevo in tempo rischiavo che
arrivasse in italia direttamente via
mare quindi quando ho visto questo mi sono
illuminata perché ovviamente é
impermeabile quindi può accadere
ovunque anche in mare
e non succede assolutamente nulla l'ho
scelto di questo colore perché di solito
in estate mi faccio le unghie di questo
colore quindi top adoro matcherá con
le mie unghie
passiamo all'abbigliamento sobrissimo che ho
acquistato a miami proprio un tocco di
sobrietà non indifferente partendo da
questo vestito che ho preso da forever21
l'ho visto ho detto va beh io con
questo diventerò donatella versace
probabilmente infatti l'ho preso é top
adoro oro nero
figuriamoci poi sempre da forever21
ho preso questo completo pazzesco in
velluto prugna che colore è questo un
prugna c'è il pantacollant a vita alta e
poi c'è il suo toppino quindi pancia di
fuori in velluto non si capisce bene in
quale stagione dovrei metterlo ovviamente
in inverno perché d'estate il velluto no con
il blazer sopra tacco e ciao fashion
week a chi ma a proposito di
fashion week e di eleganza vi volevo far
vedere questo croptop sempre di velluto
leopardato con lo sfondo rosa quindi
proprio una sciccheria veramente da
ghetto che però mi piace un sacco
ultima cosa che ho preso da forever21
tanti di voi ahimè non
conosceranno questo film è questa t
shirt questo croptop perché ha
la pancia di fuori di cruel intentions
allora io so che voi andate fuori di
testa per gossip girl ma vi devo svelare
un segreto anche a me piace un sacco
gossip girl prima di gossip girl
c'è stato un film cioè cruel intentions
che era praticamente il l'antenato di
gossip girl c'erano più o meno le stesse
dinamiche tutti ricchi eccetera eccetera
bellissimo se non l'avete visto andatelo a
vedere invece da urban outfitters ho
trovato questa che adoro
mi mancava di tartan ne ho di tutti i
colori mi mancava solo il giallo e mi sa molto
da vi ricordate il video di fancy di iggy azalea ecco "i'm so fancy" ecco lei ce l'aveva uguale
molto anni 90 l'adoro
concludiamo con victoria's secret a
miami ovviamente c'era il negozio ma
soprattutto c'erano i saldi
non ho mai visto così tanto panico in un
negozio proprio la gente impazzita le
cose effettivamente costavano molto poco
ho comprato questo body che era sempre in
saldo l'avrò pagato anche lì 15 euro
penso di usarlo per il prossimo video
dei cattivi della disney tutorial di
halloween
perché proprio in the mood molto molto
sberluccicoso praticamente appena lo prendi lo
tocchi hai la mano piena di brillantini
quindi per coloro che vogliono brillare
con e senza body ultimo acquisto ultimi
acquisti questi due beauty case
io sono piena di beauty case
salvo mi aveva regalato uno beauty case di
victoria secret comodissimo che si
appende proprio con l'appennino quindi da
viaggio è pazzesco uno dei regali più
azzeccati di sempre e ne ho tanti altri
di varie marche eccetera eccetera i beauty
case non bastano mai
sapete quanto li ho pagati 5 euro l'uno
qui a milano forse costano 50 euro
utilissimi sono praticamente vedete gli aprite
li potete usare anche
semplicemente così senza le bustine
dentro mettendoci i trucchi dentro
oppure potete dividere quindi magari qui
mettete i pennelli qui le tinte labbra
eccetera eccetera sono super comodi e
soprattutto in valigia li potete utilizzare anche tutti e due e li
mettete così e avete tutti i vostri
trucchi a portata di mano
mi sono appena resa conto che ho fatto
tutto il video con l'etichetta che si
vedeva e grazie edoardo per avermi
informato lui l'ha fatto apposta cosí ho fatto
tutto il video così il video finisce qua
spero tanto che vi siano piaciuti i miei
acquisti fatemi sapere con un commentino
qui sotto
cosa avete preferito e ci vediamo al
prossimo video haul
vi mando un bacione e ricordatevi sempre
questa volta lo cambio il finale
la sobrietà prima di tutto